- deux tours hlm plus de maisons et de
verdure la source ce quartier populaire
près d'orléans s'est transformé depuis
2003 les travaux se multiplient deux
programmes de rénovation ont été lancés
les grandes étapes sont retracés dans
cette exposition des photos des dates
clés sont affichées sur ces panneaux
dispersés dans le quartier il est
important aussi de garder en mémoire
toute l'histoire de ce qu'on était avant
et de ce que notre quartier devient
aujourd'hui avant vous avez tout le
quartier qui à l'arrière où on ne
pouvait pas y accéder aussi facilement
qu'ils ont été totalement
résidentialisés est effectivement
aujourd'hui on a la possibilité de se
balader à la sauce sans se dire sans se
retourner en se disant j'ai peur cette
rénovation urbaine en tout cas permis de
réduire l'insécurité à la source baisse
des violences selon l'élu se quartiers
dits prioritaires a bénéficié d'une aide
publique
près de 300 millions d'euros débloqués
pour offrir un meilleur cadre de vie aux
habitants j'en ai parlé avec des
personnes qui vivent là depuis très
longtemps est ici dans le quartier et
qui disent qu'il fait bon vivre à la
source que les immeubles ont été refaits
ils ont refait des façades des immeubles
à l'intérieur des salles de bains ont
été refaites
ces bénévoles s'affairent au tgp nous
sommes en train de préparer les articles
pour le prochain numéro de l'indien le
numéro 134 depuis 1984 ce journal
communique sur les différents plans de
rénovation engagés par la ville nous
avons suivi dans tous les plans de
rénovation tout l'est depuis
à peu près 2000 2004 et actuellement le
plan qui démarre
peut-être un petit peu lentement mais
qui avance quand même parmi les
chantiers à venir qui prennent du retard
la démolition de la tour 17 mythique
dans le quartier elle ne devrait pas
être détruite avant l'année prochaine